civil rights attorney ben crump is known
for his battles for justice for trayvon
martin george floyd and brianna taylor
just to name a few now he's fighting for
the victims of the racist buffalo
grocery store attack we remember this
where 10 black people were killed trump
is also the focus of a new netflix
documentary it's called civil it follows
him for one pivotal year in 2020 when
george floyd's death changed the world
we're getting an exclusive look
people seek me out because they want
somebody they feel they can trust
it's not just fighting racism and
discrimination in these police shooting
cases it's fighting racism and
discrimination wherever it reads its
ugly head
you have to try to not just be a
spectator on the sidelines get into the
arena and do so
get into the arena and do something ben
crump joins us now good morning to you
mr crump people say you get into the
arena a lot a lot but let's start with
buffalo because you're representing some
of those the families there what does
justice look like for them
it looks like holding not only this
individual who committed this
offer act of hate accountable but also
holding those who
curate the hate those who are at the
root of the hate holding them
accountable as accomplices they may
not have pulled the trigger that killed
those 10
innocent people in that grocery store
but they certainly loaded the gun gail
are there any new developments in that
case well we have just found out that
many of the families are going to the
united states senate on next tuesday to
provide testimony
before hearing on gun reform and the
rise of white supremacy in america
last night president biden said he wants
to ban assault weapons in high-capacity
magazines what do you think we need to
do to stop these mass shootings
well i think that's certainly a step in
the right direction i can't fathom nate
why a person needs a
ar-15 gun
but you also have to get to
a lot of what we talk about in the
documentary teaching civility talking
about people being civil to one another
and
choosing social justice over this lynch
mob mentality
choosing
tolerance and respect over this notion
of white supremacy choosing and
advocating for humanity over
inhumanity
let's talk about this netflix
documentary because it's a big deal it's
going to open the uh the american black
film festival in miami in about a week
it's directed by the same individual who
directed becoming the michelle obama
documentary it's called civil and it
opens with a voicemail message from a
relative of george floyd which begins
your connection to that family and in
the in the introduction we called it the
year that changed america changed the
world looking back do you think it
changed the world
i think in many ways it changed the
world it raised a consciousness level
that we
have an obligation to be civil to one
another to
understand and respect the humanity and
everyone i think about
tony
one of the most significant cause to
actions in american history was 2020.
you can't plan that
this brilliant
young director nadia holgren
masterfully captured moments that i
didn't even realize was happening and
i'm very grateful to tara sarandos and
the whole netflix family for saying you
know we think it's important to
highlight this type of work this type of
activism fighting in the courtroom and
out the courtroom for humanity in a
civil manner yeah listen i think the
documentary is very well done i think
people get to see all different sides of
you we see your daughter we see your
wife see how you became ben crump and
you say that you want to make it
financially unsustainable for black
people to be killed in this country what
do you mean by that because then it goes
back to well there's ben crump showing
up again he's trying to make a profit
can you explain what you're doing and
why you do it certainly gail
you know
every morning i wake up and i i pray
that we get to close down the police
brutality division in my law firm
because that would mean
we wouldn't have to lose trayvon we
wouldn't have to lose brianna we
wouldn't have to lose george florida and
pamela turner both of them jane all
these young people who have such
a future ahead of them cut down because
of senseless violence and that's what i
fight for police brutality
and these cases make up less than five
percent of what i do but i didn't
realize that ben because it seems
whenever you're on tv you're there
because someone has been shot do you
represent white people by the way too i
represent okay anyway people in fact uh
hunter and bb arkansas was a young white
boy shot by the police and we
represented his family but you go when
you're called i think we should make
that point you just don't show up but
you're trying to make it financially
unsustainable so for those critics that
say it's not passion it's profit for him
yes yeah what do you say i just say you
know
one thing we all have to understand is
that
america is a capitalistic society and
what we're fighting for is to say
ces is valuable whether we're black
white red or brown yeah and we don't
want you to kill our children too and
how do we stop it i want to use
everything i can you know kenya barris
created blackish and now he's the
executive producer of this one thing we
talked about when we were talking about
this it's trying to
give value to black people and brown
people so we can be looked at as equal
not only in theory but in reality yeah
i've heard you speak and you talk about
how we move forward and not living in
fear is that tough to do for you as an
individual when you're receiving death
threats because you talked about that as
well in this film because it's one thing
to brush off
people saying that we don't like you
it's another thing for thousands of
people saying we are going to kill you
yeah yeah and i think about what
happened in buffalo nate and it that we
don't take the death threats lightly we
take them seriously
but i believe that god blessed me with
this influence and shame on me if i
don't use this influence to try to do
everything i can to help those who don't
have a voice at the end of the day
this is about trying to make a better
world for all of our children and if i
can do that then my living won't be in
value even if it costs your life even if
you cause your life you have to say what
is your
fear yeah i won't live in fear your
mentor was thurgood marshall yeah what
did he tell you and then we're going to
say goodbye yes ma'am gail the
first time i got to meet my personal
hero justice thurgood marsha at the
supreme court with other young people
these historical black college students
who were with me he came over and he
told us young aspiring lawyers go into
courtrooms and don't argue what is legal
he said you go into courtrooms and you
argue what is right
and that was so profound to me i never
forgot that gayle king argue what is
right and now more than ever this
documentary is about saying let's do
what is right love over hate humanity
over in humanity yep well it's very
powerful i think people will get to see
really different sides to you and i
thought very well done congratulations
ben crump thank you for joining us yeah
thank you again
very much it's an honor how do you
remember everybody's name too whenever
you're talking to people you always say
their names
nicely done
the netflix documentary civil comes out
on june uh on june teens which is sunday
june 19th
rebecca on june 12th and tribeca on june
12th we'll be right back